Selamlar sevgili dostlar. Umarım
iyisinizdir. Ailenizle, anneniz
babanızla, sağlıklı, kardeşlerinizle
güzel zamanlar geçiriyorsunuzdur. İş
arıyorsanız güzel iş fırsatları
sizinledir. Eee, umutsuzluk
içerisinde içerisindeyseniz eğer de eee
güzel günler. Umarım yakında sizinle
olur sevgili arkadaşlar. Eee, bugün
sevgili dostlar bir önceki aslında
seride başlamıştım. Flightterda
refactoring master class diye bir seri
yapıyordum. Bunda üç video yayınladım.
Bu üç videoda ne yapmıştık? Özetle
projeyi inceledik. Pubspack yamal dedik.
Kods standartları linter falanı konuştuk
böyle küçük küçük videolarla. Şimdi
bugün de arkadaşlar videonun 4üncü
kısmında bunu şöyle biraz daha
düzenledim burayı. Videonun 4üncü
kısmında biraz proje mimarisi klasör
yapısından konuşuyor olacağız. Fature
base yapı, modü yapı, core feature
product şeklinde sadece klasörleri
düzenlediğim bir örnekten paylaşacağım.
E şu an uygulamanın herhangi bir
içindeki coding'e geçmedim daha. Daha
oraya var. Oraya geçene kadar sadece şu
anlık yan tarafı açtım. Onun için şu an
şurayı kapatıyorum. Oraya geçene kadar
arkadaşlar şu an sadece codingde
kalalım. Ondan sonrasından da
ilerletelim. Şimdi eee proje yapısı
mimarisini yapacağımız için şurada ben
şu bizim Flight Booking'e geleyim.
Aslında burada bir işi oluşturabilirdim
de. Tamam bunu sonra ben oluştururum
onu. Şimdi bir saat biz de bununla
uğraşmayalım. Şu anlık GCB feature
diyeceğim. Project
eee structure diyeyim şuraya.
Structor V4 diyeyim buna da. En azından
anlaşılır olsun. Şimdi sevgili dostlar
bu project extractor kısmı özellikle
yine bizim bu tarz yani refactoring ve
master class diyorsak yani önemli bir
şey diyorsak en önemli olan bir tanesi.
Çünkü projeye girdiğinizde birçok
projelere girdikçe mesela benim gibi siz
de gördükçe en önemli kısmın aslında eee
burası olduğunu herkes söyler ve aslında
bunun önemi şundan kaynaklanır. Bireysel
bir proje geliştirdiğinizde her şey her
şey her yere gelebilir. Bundan yine
problem yok. Ama takım çalışması
düşüncesinde proje yapısı neyi nereye
koyacağınızı bir anlamlandırmak çok
önemlidir. Burada iki kısma çok dikkat
etmenizi rica ediyorum. Sektörde en çok
gördüğüm şey bu. Mesela tek başına bir
arkadaşın gidip de işte bir Viper'ıdır
işte Cinarctir paternleriyle bir
bireysel bir projede yapması aslında bir
bakıma biraz saçma. Şöyle saçma amaç
zaten teste doğru giden yol olduğu için
vesaire bunlar test tabii ki yazacağız
ama bu kadar close pad'ler, bu kadar
dosyalamalar bu kadar şey yapmanın çok
bir anlamı yok. Amaca yönelik projeye
yönelik veya duruma yönelik çözümlerle
gitmek daha mantıklı. Ondan dolayı bu
tarz aslında patenler, işler, genel
konjonktörler sadece birilerinin egosu
okşansın 10 dosya daha fazla olsun diye
değil. Tabii ki de işe yaraması için.
İşe yaramadan kasıt nedir? Tabii ki de
daha takımca team collaboration yani o
takım çalışmasına önem vermedir. Şimdi
bunun tabii üzerine yine konuşuyor
olacağız. Benim burada size önereceğim
ve şu an üzerinde duracağımız yapı
aslında bu projenin masterclass'a gelme
yolunda yapacağımız en önemli adımlardan
demince bir tanesi. Ne yapacağız? Şimdi
karşınıza geldi böyle proje. Kodlara
böyle bakıyorsunuz. Daha hani hiç şu an
burada bir sürü böyle eee coding
açısından böyle bakıyorsunuz. Aa şöyle
problemli. E bir de hep şey tabir
olacaktır. Ay şurada işte o eski kodur
işte eski yazılımcı geyi var ya hep
böyle hani işte şöyle yapılmış böyle
yapılmış. Bir de şundan hep uzak
durmanızda fayda var. Her gelen ve sizin
için ve bu benim için de iş ilk akiş
yaptığı hep kendi kafamızdakine kanalize
olmaya çalışıyoruz ama lakin burada
aslında olması gereken projenin ne y
projede biri bir şey yapmışsa bir
anlamaya çalışmak çok daha önemli.
Doğrudan dümenden hemen benimki iyidir,
benimki böyle ben kendime bütün kodları
yapayım demek aslında biraz kolaya
kaçmak oluyor. Ben hiç için öyle yapmam.
Ben kişinin ne anlatmaya çalıştığını
anlamaya çalışan bir insan olduğum için
eee size tavsiyem doğrudan hiçbir yerde
gidip de bu doğrudur ya da bunu mimari
olarak bunu alacağım demeyin. Yani
mimari yaklaşımdır. Yaklaşımı her yere
uygulayabiliyor olmanız lazım. Ezber
değildir. Onu unutmayın. Ya ben VB model
şöyle bir şey yapıyorum işte şu bu bir
ezber yaptıysan zaten sen ona gelmeye
kork onu istiyorsun projede. Yani ben
her şeyi oraya getireyim ama yaklaşımı
öğrendiysen, yaklaşımı tartışıyorsan ana
göre uydurursun. Ha bazen olumlu bazen
olumsuz. Burada da son nokta olarak şunu
söyleyeceğim. Her zaman her şeyin en
iyisi olmaz her yerde. Yani o mimari
yaklaşımı biliyor olabilirsin ama çok
uzatmadan yürümek lazım. Bir dakika
benim burada şu an durmam lazım. Çünkü
durmazsam ben ilerliyorum. Sonra video
süresi tamam. Şimdi benim bu tarafa
döneyim. Eee, paket mimarisi klasörü
future base ve core future product
klasör. Şimdi arkadaşlar böyle bir
projedeyiz zaten şu an çok karmaşık
ortalık. Biz ne yapıyoruz? İlk etapta
geliyoruz. Benim en baştan beri hep
sevdiğim ve ben açıkçası bunun birinci f
projelerde takım kolaboration'de çok işe
yarayacağını düşündüğüm yaklaşımı size
hemen burada entegre ediyorum. Diyorum
ki benim bir featlarımı toplayacağım.
Bir feature projem coldolderım olacak.
Bir tane model genel olarak projenin
içerisinde core dediğim bir kısım olacak
ki bunu biraz daha iler iyileştireceğiz
birlikte. Bir tanesinde de arkadaşlar
benim ana işlemlerim anlamında bir
product layerim olacak. Bu benim şu anki
klasör padiminde oluşacak birinci kısım
ve bu projenin yine master class ve
artikle üzerine gittiğimiz noktada
diyeceğim ki modül diye de bir sub
layerım sub folderum olacak. Burada ne
olacak diyeceksiniz arkadaşlar. Biz
burada geleceğiz. Diyeceğiz ki ya şimdi
mesela birçok projede, birçok
ilerledikçe de eee katmanların
büyüdüğünü ya da işlerin karmaşık hale
geldiğini veya mesela şöyle bir şey var.
Diyelim ki bir ekran yapıyorsunuz. Tamam
mı? Diyorsunuz ki ben burada bir işte
eee
proje yapacağım. Yani bir tane ekranımın
bir tane sayfasını yapacağını düşün.
Şimdi bir saniyenizi alıyorum şurada.
Heh. Şuradan bir tane ekran göstereyim
mesela. E hızlıca şöyle bir tane
hazırlar denelim de varsa. E mesela
Figma'dan var mı şurada bir tane Free
Kitten mesela şuradan hazırlasaydım
keşke bunun da orada ufak karıştı ama
neyse çok önemli değil ya. Mesela free
mobile free Figma free kitan
alayım mesela
ya. Mesela şu Cafe Shop çok önemli
değil. Mesela şu Cafe Shop için
konuşuyor olalım. Ya buradaki ekranı
yapıyor olduğunuzu varsayın. Bu alt
modüllerde ya şöyle bir şey var. şu
komponent olabilir. Mesela buton bir
komponent olabilir veya şu bir kart
komponent olabilir. Bu kart komponenti
senin projenin productıdır. Yani senin
projenin özelidir. Ama bu kart
komponentinin veya şu senin aslında
içerisindeki renklerin, belli başlı
şeylerin aslında proje bağımsız kodlanıp
her projede kullanabileceğin şekle
getirebileceğin formu uydurabilirsin.
Bunun meali aslında biz alt modüllerle
bu tarz her projede veya third party bir
insanın da kodlayabileceği şekilde işler
çıkartek. Mesela bu kartı öyle bir
kodlayacaksın ki mesela önüne gelen buna
bir contribution yapabilecek ama
product'ı de etkilemeyecek. Çünkü o
kendi feature base'inde olacak gibi. Alt
modüllere bunları koyabiliriz. Alt
modüllere generation'larımızı koyacağız.
Alt modüllere belki bir database
katmanımızı alacağız ve ana projeyi çık
hep dışarıda tutacağız. Ondan dolayı
burada biz modüler bir yaklaşımda ilerle
modüler bir yaklaşımda kullanıyor
olacağız. O modüler yaklaşımı
kullanırken de arkadaşlar bunun birkaç
tane yöntemi var. Bunun üzerine
konuşuyor olacağız. Bunu da burada
aslında artık bu proje artık ref şey
dendiği için master class. Orada da
belki üzerinde dururum. Çok da belki
kullandığım değil ama hani pro şey
community kullanıldığını bildiğim için
ben burada diyeceğim ki bir tane
template oluşturayım buna. E şu anlıkta
template'im librarymin adına şey
diyeceğim. Eee, ya şu anlık y diyelim
mesela. Çok önemli değil bu. Hani pardon
template'imi package diyeceğim. Adına da
mesela is diyebilirim. Yani ileride bunu
düzelteceğiz. Şu anlık bir tane utility
oluşturalım. İleride bunu dediğim gibi
konfigüre edeceğiz. Ama şu anlık biz eee
folder pad'timizi böyle oluşturduğunu
düşünelim. Yani amacımız nedir? Şimdi bu
core, bu core'u da ilerleyen zamanda
alacağız. Bu core aslında projenin
hiçbiriyle bağımsız, hiçbir şeyle işi
olmayan yerin olan yer. Yani mesela
benim ilerleyen raddelerde kullanacağım
proje katmanlarında belki benim burada
core katmanında package'larım olacak.
Dedim burada en önemli kural hiçbir
şekilde dışarıdan bir şey buraya etki
etmeyecek. Önemli kural bu. Burada
mesela benim belki bir constantlarım
olacak. Mesela constantlarım olacak
burada. Ben bu korumun altında belki
util saklayacağım. Mesela nasıl bir util
yapacağım? Diyeceğim ki buraya
geldiğimde işte eee mesela string helper
yapacağım bir tane mesela şöyle diyeyim.
String helper dark diyeceğim. Mesela
buraya bir tane final class. Şöyle bir
tane string helper'ımı oluşturacağım.
Buraya diyeceğim ki mesela eee ne
yapalım? String eee şey eee void check
URL mesela hani diyelim bunu buradan
yapıyorsunuz. Ha mesela şöyle bir
kodunuz var diyelim. hani çok eee şey
bağımsız kod konu bağımsız. Şuraya da
string atayalım ki burada böyle bir
kodunuz var diyelim. Bunları mesela
burada topluyor olacağız. Amacımız
mesela buraya şeyini de yapalım. Eee
amacımız projenin bağımsız yani burada
mesela gördüğünüz gibi hiçbir paket yok
paket yok bir şey yok. Eee alttan gelen
bir şey yok. Burada topluyor olacağım.
Şimdi feature feature ise benim
işlerimin olduğu sadece modüllerimin
yani projenin sayfalarının içinde iş
yaptığı kısımlar olacak. Mesela benim şu
an burada baktığım nelerim var? Flight
var, login var, splash var. Ben burada
genelde bunu otantike ve unotantike
olarak ayırıyorum ki daha güzel
görebileyim de. Mesela unout yazıyorum
buraya. Bu otike featurı burada
toplayayım. Buraya da out diye
topluyorum mesela. Out diye topluyorum.
Bir de featur'larımın altında arkadaşlar
sub feature şeklinde burada klasörler
koşturuyorum. Bu sub featur'ları da
neden oluşturduğumuzu ilerleyen zamanda
söyleyeceğim. Mesela eee yine dizayndan
açık diyelim. Diyelim ki bir tane şurada
bir e mesela bir komponent tabii örnek
komponenti bakmak lazım önceden diyelim
ya şurada bir tane komponentinize bir
button sheet açıyor diyelim ama buttom
sheet de bir iş yapıyor bir anlamı var
yani mesela diyelim işte gidip kart
sayfasına bir şeyler yapıyor vesaire
burada bir logiksel var bu aslında bir
feature ama başlı başına da kocaman bir
feature değil bu sub feature aslında
bakıldığında yani aslında bu iki
katmanın ana katmanların içinde olan
daha küçük işlemlerin olduğu yerleri
burada topluyorum Ben mesela burada
payment diye bir kısım oluşturup payment
bilmem nelerini burada tutuyorum ki
burada daha rahat yönetebileyim. Tamam
ben bu otantike ve anotentike olarak
açtım. Otantikin içerisinde de mesela
benim neyim var mesela şu an? Flight'ım
var mesela. Flight'ı açtım. Burada
mesela un out case'de loginim var.
Loginimi açtım. Eee başka benim burada
bir şeyim flight detail var mesela. Şu
anlık flight'ın altına topluyor
olacağım. Bu klasörlerin içerisindeki
eee daha alt klasörlemeleri de konuşuyor
olacağız. Şu anlık tamamen bizim
buradaki amacımız genel olarak klasör
yapısı, ana modülleri göstermek.
İlerleyen katmanlarda sevgili arkadaşlar
bunların işte şu VV modellar falan
filanlar işte bu managerlar falan burada
daha detaylı şeyleri anlatıyor olacağım.
Hangisini neye koyacağını. Biz şu an
sadece klasör pad'lerine odaklanalım.
Yani ondan dolayı mesela ben buraya
geldiğimde antike anotentikeyi konuştum.
Anotikede splash de olacaktır muhakkak.
Splash'i de aldım buraya. Otantik de
mesela kart sayfası var. Kartı aldım
buraya. Buraya bir tane de mesela şey
alayım şu anlık. Flight detail mesela.
Şimdi burada fikir olarak hocam o oraya
gelir mi? Bu tarz işlerde özellikle çok
fazla detaya girmeden ana fikirde
oynayıp sürekli ilerlemek lazım. Yani
mesela ben bunu yaptım. Login page'imi
attım buraya. Flight'ımı buraya attım.
Ondan sonra flight detail'ımı buraya
attım. E login response model. Şu an
login olduğu için buraya attım. Profile
page'imi geldim. Bizim şu an bir
profileimiz yok mesela. Profile de
outadır diye düşündüğüm için profile
aldım. Profile'ı buraya aldım. Profile'ı
geldim. Hop bunun içerisine attım. Ondan
sonra splash'ımı buraya attım. Eee,
flight response diyor. Yine flight'ın
içerisine alalım. Eee, card page diyor
mesela. Card page'imizi sanki şurada bir
yerde oluşturmuştuk. Şöyle bir bütün
değişiklikleri de kaydedeyim. Burada bir
import hatası verir bu. Şunu da
importunu fixleyelim.
Flight response model. Bakayım nereye
gitti o.
Response model.
E burada
yanlış mı yaptık bunu?
He tamam geldi. Tamam süper. Bu da
oturdu yerine geldi. Mesela checkout
response. Checkout'umuz var mı?
Checkoutu şu anlık karta atayım. Hadi
bunu da checkout kartının içerisindedir
diyorum. Mesela şu an buradaki aslında
genel kart proje yapısını entegre etmiş
oluyoruz. Şuraya şunu da entegre edelim.
Şuraya neredekine hata veriyor burada?
Bakayım.
Bir tane modeli bulamadı burada.
Import yok mu arkadaşlar? Import k
checkout response model şurada işte.
Card page buradasın.
Bu
heh tamam gördü. Bazen importta
göremedim. Tamam süper. burasını gördü
ve benim aslında genel projemin bak ilk
bakışta daha hiçbir şey yapmadan
yerlerini toplamış oldum. Sonrasında ben
geldim mesela dedim ki bak benim bir
Firebase işim varmış. Daha tabii
detaylarını bilmiyorum ama mesela bir
Firebase logicim varmış. Ben hemen o
Firebase login gelip diyorum ki hocam
benim Firebase işim bu productımın
altında olması gerekiyor. Bu productin
özelinde bir iş bu. O zaman ben bu
productımın içerisine bir package diye
katman kurayım. Burada yöneteyim bunu.
Sonrasında yine yarın benim altımda
işlemler olabilir. Ben bui buraya
koyayım. Ardından mesela package'in
altına Firebase deyip yarın Firebase'in
messagingi gelecek. Bir şeyler gelecek.
Hepsi burada toplansın diye buraya aldın
mı bu? Tamam. Ardından mesela ben bu
yine main dartımın içerisinde yapacağım
işlemler için hocam ben buraya bir
initialize
initialize diye bir katman yapayım
şuraya. Bu initialize'in içerisine de
main dartımı atayım hocam. Tamam mı?
Bunu neden yapıyorum? Yarın eee yeni bir
katman, yeni bir iş geldiğinde şöyle
bakayım. Şunu görmüş olması lazım. Heh.
Yeni bir şey geldiğinde bu iniş ilacımın
içerisine yapayım dedin mi? Dedim. Ve
artık benim için şu anki raddede
bakıldığında bütün klasörler yerinde.
Yarın ben bir şey oluşturmak istesem
nereye bakacağımı biliyorum ve ileriye
yönelik bu refactoring'in ve
mastercass'ın ilk adımını aslında atmış
oluyorum. Şimdi bundan sonra tabii
ilerleyeceğimiz kısımlar var ama ben
bundan sonra burada durmak istiyorum.
Çünkü benim buradaki derdim şu an için.
Öncelikle size bu klasörleri neden
oluşturdum? E bu klasörleri yarın e siz
yaparken de dikkat edeceksiniz veya eile
tabii ki promt engineering'le yaptığınız
noktada nelere dikkat ederek yaptırmanız
gerektirdiğini de ufak bir aslında s'le
alıp he ben bunu böyle yaparsam buradan
böyle toplarım, bunları böyle
gösteririmle kafanızda oturtarak gitmiş
olacaksınız. Bakın buradaki en önemli
kısım dediğim gibi takım çalışmasına
uygun takımın içerisinde olduğunda daha
iyi geliştirebileceğim modülleri de
burada görebilmek. Şu anlıkta zaten buna
küçük küçük başlıyoruz. Bu küçük küçük
başlamalarla bu projenin kodlarını
tertemiz hale getirdikten sonrasında
yine ilgili klassları işte mesela login
page'in refactoringini, splash page'in
refactoring'ini vesairesini yaptıktan
sonrasında rahat rahat aslında diğer
işlemleri de yapıyor ve götürüyor
olacağız arkadaşlar. Bakın işte şurada
mesela preference logicleri böyle
bunların hepsini toplayacağız ama şu
anlık bu içeriklik bu kadar. Eee bunu da
şuradan hatta hemen comitleyelim. Bakın
şu an bile aslında bayağı e temiz bir
versiyona gelmiş olduk sevgili
arkadaşlar. Hemen refactoring zaten
refactoring adı üstünde direkt mesela 35
fis burada bir de bu şeyde en çok
eklemek istediğim şey şu arkadaşlar
genel olarak TR piyasasında ya globalde
de böyle gerçi TR piyasası hani ben
globalde ekiplerde gördüğümde de
aynısını görüyorum. eee insanlar silmeye
kork yani silmek eklemek kolaydır ya
hocam benim yapıyı getir bunu herkes der
ama var olanı editlemek var olanı
düzeltmeye çabalamak bu bir fikir
gerektirir. Bu bir araştırma gerektirir.
Yapay zekanın size gösterdiği yerle
doğru yöre götürmeyebilir. Burada o
fikre sahipseniz nereye gideceğini
bilirsiniz. Ondan dolayı ben size
approach yaklaşım hep yaklaşım vermeye
çalışıyorum ki bu seride zaten bu
şekilde yaklaşımlarla gidiyor olacak
sevgili arkadaşlar demiş. olayım. Eee,
artık bir sonraki diğerlerinde diğer
seride görüşmek üzere. Kendinize iyi
bakın. Kolay gelsin. İyi çalışmalar
diliyorum arkadaşlar.